with information there is always a cost  you used to be a crime reporter in japan  why  you think the clothes are foreigner the  roads are different  yeah  listen you like busting my balls huh it  is a great joy of my life  giving up and going home is not an  option you know what i mean you know  exactly what you mean  [Music]  and let me guess  this is how you recruit a cop  [Music]  [Applause]  hika with information  everything you do has consequences  there is always a cost  [Music]  jake this is sato he's not as brooding  as he seems  [Music]  what's it like to be a yakuza i could  write about that yes  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  this world  once you open the door  it is very hard to close  [Music]  don't write about this  [Music]  [Applause]  you